the a's leading the west by a game in
half at a play tonight with a record of
28 and 20. for the athletics it'll be
frankie motas on the mound so that'll
bring up the hammer right fielder mitch
haniger haniger
batting 257 with 13 home runs 31 runs
bad and then
hannigan banning 321 with runners on and
scoring position
montas looks in has a sign checks
kelnick
here's the stretch and the right hand is
one-two pitch swinging a line drive down
the left field line a fair ball in
toward the corner celtic rounding third
heading home he'll score easily the
throw will go into second slide into the
second with an rbi double goes mitch
haniger and the mariners have a very
quick one to nothing lead here in the
top of the first
nobody out here's the veteran kyle
seeger left hand batter
look back at second and the one two
swinging a foul tip upstairs murph hangs
on for strike
three and seeker who came into the game
batting around 450 with runners in
scoring position is denied that's the
first out and here comes kyle lewis
chapman deep at third base and the one
two swing and a miss upstairs high
octane at 95 and that gets lewis for
route number two france stands in two
for 34 in the month of may
and his average overall now is 229 with
three homers and 14 driven in the
stretch
the leg kick the pitch fastball strike
three called on the outside corner
97 on ty france
but the m's get an early run with one
hit they leave two at the end of a half
the mariners one and the a's are
coming up you say kikuchi he's winless
in may he's one and three overall a 4.32
era they're 21-26 on the earth one
aboard for the a's here's first baseman
matt olsen here's the pitch swung on and
it's popped up shallow left field down
the line keltnik racing into foul
territory reaches out and he makes the
catch out by the oakland bullpen
fine running catch by jared kelneck in
davao territory down the left field line
and that'll end the inning we go to the
top half of the second from the oakland
coliseum
i'm going to bring donovan walton to the
plate
one two swing and a miss there's the
split finishes them off and a one two
three inning and back on the beam for
frankie montas onto the bottom of the
second it's one nothing seattle
judd lowry the d.h banning 248 four home
runs 26 runs batted in lowry set out
last year he was with the mets two years
ago
cleaning just nine games with new york
two-two pitch swaying and a miss and a
cutter for strike three and there's
strikeout number one for you say kikuchi
he fans jed lowry here in the bottom
half of the second one away for the a's
mariners lead one and up here
here's kyle seeger
struck out in the first
anger leads from first montas long look
in and the pitch is swung on and missed
splitter
and key seeger k's for the second time
that's five strikeouts for montas
they'll bring up kyle lewis he struck
out on a high fastball
in the first inning
a 1-2 pitch from montas here it comes to
lewis fastball swung on driven deep to
left and just taking a look is mark
canada that baby's gone two-run homer
for kyle lewis and the mariners have a
three-nothing lead here in the third
what a blast by lewis his fourth home
run rbi seven and eight
pitts top of the zone got the barrel to
it and wrote it out
three infielders on the right side for
crawford walked back in the first and
from the wind-up
montage kicks and fires and the one-two
pitch swinging a miss
crawford out in front of a splitter
and he's down on strikes
6k for montas
but the mariners strike for two in the
third on a two-run home run
by kyle lewis we're through two and a
half the mariners three and the a's
nothing
and now back to the top of the lineup
for canna
kikuchi set
and here it comes and kanna swings and
drives one out toward right field back
goes haniger still going back at the
track he turns around and it's gone
marcanna
on a 2-2 pitch
drives one out the other way
just over the wall and right off the
stairs out there and that one just kept
carrying got a high fastball
good short swing
and kind of back spun it out of here
that's his tenth of the year three to
one mariners
bender bounced into a double play in the
first inning yakuchi comes set
3-2 depender
breaking ball swung on hit the right
field in the gap it's hanging up kyle
lewis dives to his left and makes the
catch nicely done
in the a's third a home run by canna
they're on the board and we go to the
fourth inning it's the marinus three the
asian
so here
is donovan walton struck out swinging
back in the second
left-handed hitting second baseman and
here comes the o2 pitch swinging and a
miss
slider down below the zone walton is
down on strikes
and montas
works around a lead off double to keep
the mariners
off the board in the fourth
through three and a half the mariners
three and the a's one
helnik led off the game of the walk went
to second on a wild pitch should have
been a pass ball
then scored on a double by mitch haniger
last time up flow out to right here's a
swing and a high fly ball into right
field backing up is piscotty looking up
and goodbye baseball
way out of here to right field jared
kellnick with his second big league home
run it hits on the stairway it's
trickling back down the stairs like a
slinky right now it keeps rolling down
step after step after step and the
mariners now lead the a's
four to one here in the top half of the
fifth and what a shot by kelly he's
trailing four to one and here comes kyle
seeger
one two a wave and a miss finished him
off with a split
and that's eight strikeouts for motos
which he would gladly trade in
if he could be leading in the score or
at least get a couple of balls back that
left the ballpark
and that'll bring ty france to the plate
the stretch the pitch
swung on rolled left side elvis has it
the short stop over to first base is
going to be in time
and the inning is over run home on the
kelnick blast to right sends us to the
bottom of the fifth inning it is 4-1
seattle here's catcher sean murphy
garfield for one has grounded out to
short
here's the stretch and the pitch strike
three called with a fastball he got him
looking you say kikuchi
with his second strikeout of the ball
game he banned jed lowry back in the
second and now he gets murphy with the
strikeout
here is right fielder steven piscotti
now the one pitch of the way swinging a
ground ball to third backhanded sliding
stop secret down to second for one the
relay to first not in time
but they get the outer champion at
second base on a tremendous play by kyle
siegert third quickly to his right
mac handed the ball sliding to his right
inside the bag he spins on his left knee
pops up he throws a strike to donovan
walton
they get chapman at second the relay the
first was a little bit late but what a
play
here comes donovan walton
the wind up and the one-two pitch
fastball strike three called over the
inside corner got him with 97 on the
edge and he strikes out the side he's
got 11 on the night
but the a's have got to go to work
bottom of the sixth inning oakland
trailing 4-1 we take a look at you say
it looks like
maybe he's having a little yeah he's
calling timeout a little bit of an issue
with his back he's pointing towards his
back so hopefully isn't anything serious
and also notice that during the game
when we would show him in the dugout he
was standing up a lot so maybe it was
something that he was dealing with and
now just finally caught him and had to
get him out of the game brown now
has eight home runs and 18 rbis in 35
games and the 3-1 pitch and that's swung
on a drilled deep right center on its
way toward the wall and it's off the
wall in play kemp's racing around third
the relay by crawford and he's not going
to get him he slides in safely and the
a's get one back they trail four to two
and that'll bring up first baseman matt
olson
brown on its second
canna the timed run on it first base
swanson ready and the 2-2 pitch swing at
a miss and a fast ball for strike three
and eric swanson strikes out the side
here in the bottom of the eighth inning
and the a's leave the time run stranded
holy smokes what a performance by eric
swanson and the battle will be catcher
shawn murphy murphy is old for three on
the night
middleton's 1-2
he got him swinging and that's the ball
game the mariners win it they come to
the coliseum and they take game one
from the division's top dog